you know who we haven't spoken to for a
while our other cancun caller it's bit
defender bitdefender welcome
hey david how are you
how are you
i'm fine excellent what's on your mind
today
um i was listening enjoying your monday
theme show
about critical race theory
and there was a point in the show in
which you mentioned how
angry
and how mad
people got at these
rallies and events
i do believe there's
some element of
heightened anger
you know republicans seem more prone to
outrage in this sense um i think because
of the culture war but that's beside the
point okay the question is
given that
anger and stress
usually have negative health
consequences
and this is a bit of a random question
do you think maybe in the future we will
see
um
you know statistically significant
enough
differences in health outcomes by
political ideology
well we already might what's wrong so
there's a very interesting thing about
that which is
the red states on average have worse
health care systems and lower uh life
expectancy it's it's already the case
now
there's a real question as to whether
within those states
there's a difference in life expectancy
based on political ideology but like for
example mississippi which is one of the
reddest states has very bad health care
and
you know connecticut which is a very
blue state has very good health care so
we already see that
the the counterbalance is
i believe it's still true that
conservatives on average have more kids
than liberals
so you could i mean it's it's
complicated math but you could have a
situation where
the the republicans have lower life
expectancy but they're reproducing more
quickly and that allows them to keep
winning elections it's it's
we need more data to answer the question
but it's an interesting one
well i i mean i don't know about
um
influencing electoral outcomes yeah you
know the question is mostly yeah like
individual health outcomes on average
uh given the externalities of stress and
you know heightened negative emotion
right
yeah i mean it's a question that we just
need data to answer and it's data that i
don't have the data we do have though is
that on average life expectancy is
longer in blue states and it would stand
to reason that if you extrapolated that
out
on average on average you may well be
right that leftists have a slightly
longer life expectancy than right
wingers by virtue of where they live not
because of their ideology you're asking
a more specific question but but i think
it's a fascinating one i don't know the
answer
you know is it one of those questions
that pop into your mind um because you
you
you know you know you you are a busy
person you live stress on a daily basis
i guess
um
i suppose you can tell that it does take
a toll on your health
um i can't imagine what it would be to
live
in a
world in which
you know
most of the
republican beliefs are well certainly
true for them you know yeah um
[Music]
but yeah anyway that was my question
thank you very much hey how how are it's
been years since i've been to cancun how
are things there right now
well you know the city keeps growing um
big
urban problems keep uh you know
happening you keep popping up with this
is a city for that was originally
designed for 250 000 people and we're
breaking 1.1 million i think wow uh you
know there's there's issues related to
that a lot a lot of
wealth inequality between the planned
part of the city and the new parts
for you know various different reasons
related to government
um
[Music]
someone who lives there do you do you
ever go to the hotel zone or do do
locals never go to that area oh i work
at the hotel zone oh you work there okay
all right
well how about for people who are who
live there and don't work in the hotel
zone do they ever go to the hotel zone
yeah yeah so
think of it like
you live in new york i think think of it
like the the the
nicer part of town that it's not
downtown
you know it's like where the very
high-end restaurants are it's where um
usually very affluent people will just
usually just live you know like they
will eat the work and sleep in the hotel
zone
you know in incidences and whatnot but
yeah and
you will see a big wealth difference
here between the people that live here
and the people that work
got it got it got it
all right well i appreciate the call
great to hear from you again
thank you david all right there's bit
defender strongly defending bits in
cancun